está siendo aclamado como un gran
impulso a los esfuerzos para poner fin a
la guerra civil en Etiopía tigre ha
entregado sus armas pesadas como parte
de su compromiso de aplicar el acuerdo
de pretoria y el equipo de supervisión y
verificación lo ha confirmado esperamos
que esto contribuya en gran medida a
acelerar la plena aplicación del acuerdo
el desarme forma parte del acuerdo de
paz firmado hace más de dos meses para
poner fin a un mortífero conflicto en el
norte de Etiopía otros términos del
acuerdo incluyen la restauración de la
autoridad Federal en tigre y la
reapertura del acceso a la región
aislada del mundo desde mediados de 2021
los combates comenzaron en noviembre de
2022 cuando el gobierno etíope inició
operaciones militares en tigre contra el
partido gobernante de la región el
frente de liberación Popular de tigre
las fuerzas de tigre se enfrentaron a
las fuerzas de defensa etíopes que se
asociaron con las tropas de la vecina
eritrea
la situación pasado a convertirse en un
conflicto prolongado con enormes los
combates han provocado una hambruna que
afecta cientos de miles de habitantes de
tigre matando a miles de personas y
desplazando a millones en toda la región